there's something terribly wrong with
the world in which we've got more real
choice at the corner coffee shop than we
do at the ballot mark the Declaration of
Independence doesn't talk about life
liberty and the pursuit of politics
talks about the pursuit of happiness
what we do in our own private time in
there is a source code for how we might
finally improve politics in the 21st
century libertarianism always places in
all chips on black wager on the future
on the ability of free individuals to
invent more and more interesting choices
for how we can live our cause much of
what we enjoy in the 21st century the
Internet freedom to travel good beer
finally food trucks have come about as a
direct result of deregulation you want
to know why independents are growing in
number and power according to every poll
and survey it's because in a world where
our choices are Nancy Pelosi and John
Boehner the survivors will envy the dead
politicians and pundits are forever
talking about a new permanent governing
majority of this party or that in fact
what is emerging is a permanent non
governing minority of individuals and
independents who swarmed a single issue
topics to finally change politics for
the better I'm confident that my kids
are going to get to do things we can't
even imagine yet but that can only
happen if we make a stand now to reduce
the size and scope of government and the
burden it's placing on the future
you